[Music]  people high on bath salts have been  known to run naked through the streets  randomly attacking people like crazed  Dom beats it's all over the news well  here's something I've wondered how about  the people who have positive experiences  on bath salts how come you never hear  about those people that's why I wanted  to bring back a friend who is woefully  underrepresented in the media  Ronnie sunshine the incredibly helpful  bath salts addict  well oh it's Ronnie's sunshine smoking  back songs having a good time what a  groovy way to spend the day  [Music]  you've done the job  Ronny's I'm joined our friend gobo such  a great great friend  [Applause]  sunshine means well  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you